[Music]
well hello there
Greg John we are gonna watch Cobra Kai
episode 4 Cobra Kai never dies Cobra Kai
on YT read people guys I have to tell
you I cannot wait to hit play on this
alright
hit him play YouTube originals
metaphysical so this damn thing crashed
mine's one two three four
thanks for taking care of this Eduardo
it's my pleasure
they're gonna do it he's gonna ask ya
got a creepy kid
that's not cool that's not a cool way to
rock it's really cool way they're gonna
get ripped off weird we forgot all about
him yeah
hello kiss-ass
trade cans ha yeah Wylie take two babies
already got some tagging hey it's the
kid from Deadpool 2 lot pancakes it is
not easy for these guys right now no
it's not it's hard to biosis every day
they have to drive on Ventura believe
out the go ahead already
that's why guys ask because he practiced
I gotta be dead okay then he needs
Danny's help but the show needs to go on
like ponch Morrow we just cover nude for
this episode's called Cobra kind of died
you - that's so mean
you better stand up for never be a
decent oh man kid had an acting coach
cuz you know in real life he no rebel
[Laughter]
pictum about entertainment so you're
tough
[Music]
finally it was he was a racist
employees laughing I guess you must be
full after eating all that
everyone's paying attention
[Music]
didn't even need to stretch for that
kick now I use ready he stretched before
he walked in so would you do this
talking to you Lila theater here look
how people piss me off never seen that
you look hot sweetie yeah I don't his
body in the river very very sad food and
the best defense is a gun
[Laughter]
[Music]
on the high school that's right
this is son-of-a-bitch disrespecting our
family name you're gonna take that [ __ ]
cause this was cute at first I figured
it must happen but right now I didn't
want to see it I just love this show I'm
really just never want an episode and
it's like my sincerest feeling and then
when I just feel it's gonna end I'm like
give you a cue or a clue just cutting
off yeah I really like the way this
episode was handled in the sense that it
doesn't seem to be going down this route
I don't think it what's this son say I'm
Robbie or something yeah I don't think
he'll join Cobra Kai he could all
depends on execution I feel like right
now I prefer the concept he and Johnny
have to fight yeah I prefer the concept
of he can't repair his relationship with
his son like maybe way down the road but
right now he just can't as much as he's
trying to force his way in there to
being a parent there's already so much
damage that's done that element
strengthens relationship and the bond he
has with Miguel like that moment got me
a little misty I when he was telling the
mom like he's the one person who never
he gives up on me that's a very touching
moment
yeah totally and it's like he's got to
be a father figure in a way to Miguel
and Miguel is kind of teaching him how
to be a better father yeah
and I'm watching him get pushed around
at school and teaching him how to be
confident and defend himself and I
wonder if that's going to trickle over
at all like maybe through working with
Miguel over the arc of the season he'll
learn what he needs to learn to at least
start to make small amends with Robbie
or something this gives us a different
tale of master karate instructor at new
pupil like even with him he's looking at
that cheese Eve moment of the dad
sharing an ice-cream with his son at the
diner and they do this cut and you'd
think that it would be like oh it's
cutting to him talking to the mom or
talking to his actual kid but a lot of
the episode was you know you got to live
with some mistakes and there's no
do-overs given to you I don't know just
feeling that like strengthening that
bond as opposed to like yeah you know
you know Johnny really likes Miguel it
was kind of a dick but actually having a
vulnerable moment about how he feels
towards him well yeah kind of having a
character motivation that you just get
to watch yeah you know it feels very
natural you walk Cobra Kai to be
successful yeah they're gonna train
together again but the way the plot
earns that yeah it is really tasteful I
think in the way they've been handling
this I think the ending button was
interesting cuz it kind of looked like
Danny Larusso was a little happy that he
did that because this whole episode was
kind of an awakening for Danny Larusso
for the image that's been created around
him yeah you're a gimmick yeah you know
people laugh at him like he's defending
himself on you know actually was a cry
you could see he takes that very
personal when people downplay his past
karate background like he doesn't view
karate as a joke it's not like a karate
was stupid it's still a part of his
heart and that's something that I feel
like the first three episodes haven't
really been giving I mean it's like a
little flashback he had with his
daughter in one episode the sense that
the principles of karate still really
lay within his soul haven't really been
present and the fact that we've seen him
get defensive yeah shows that that's
still a part of him and he even felt
like it was rewarding for him to do that
little like yeah keep the bow bow out of
that one guy's hand to the bow bow yeah
and so when he saw that it was Johnny
Lawrence he kind of seemed like he had a
little smile on his face almost as if oh
I think this this is getting like I've
kind of been feeling like getting back
into karate yeah now this is my final
push yeah yeah he's gonna go so he can
go fight cold because before it seemed
like the only motivation that this show
was building to for Danny Larusso to
fight Johnny Lawrence was like Johnny
Lawrence is pissing me off that's the
cool thing over the course of these few
episodes I like the way they establish
both Johnny and Danny as just this
presence in each other's life like they
don't even have to be interacting hardly
at all because just like that billboard
always like grinning down at Danny and
the retaliation of that in the fliers he
finds her because you know he ran into
him in the last episode hanging him up
at the school and it just seems like
they both represent this albatross to
each other yeah they both kind of live
in the shadow of their past is just
Danny's past is much better
he's got glory days where Johnny doesn't
really have a family he's struggling to
connect to but in a totally different
way never left the valley and babygirl
Russo Terry darling LaRussa finding out
that Kyler's is a dick I don't know how
she never knew that yeah I'm like this
guy seems like a public dick and your
friends group is made up of mostly
[ __ ] always around for the most cuz
which you saw that oh good she saw a my
next thought was how'd she never know or
piece this together or observe it's a
library not even being quiet you know
how is there no like librarian I'm on
their asses immediately to be like as
the bully group doesn't like Hawker only
everybody don't do it in front of Hawker
yeah we gotta protect our brand he's not
new to the school was great that was a
nice reversal there made sense I'm like
yeah of course you would know a little
bit about she should have done that like
female action hero maneuver Black Widow
Cobra Kai Cobra Kai never dies man I
love it I love it I - alright guys well
thanks for watching